but every ration I've tested so far has
struggle with my coach load of 30 dinars
arriving and ordering all at once
they'll expect every dish to be cooked
to perfection
I want my diners to leave tonight you
know on cloud nine I want their jaws on
the floor really push it out yeah and
good luck thank you sir we got a new
order to mean come one chickens are
tight we're just going to do what we do
best and that's the quality and the
consistency of the food you don't want
to be complacent if there's thirty pad
thai there'll be 30 great pad thai it's
that simple
Marquez hand-picked a small selection of
his most popular dishes for my guests
tonight including shrimp Tom Yum chicken
satay and tiger prawn Pad Thai he's
taking these Thai classics to a new
level of sophistication with truly
authentic flavors and exquisite
presentation but upstairs front of house
our discoveries made a big mistake with
his menu
there's no vegetarian option we can
speak to chef they can prepare whatever
you like I speak the manager yes find
out why there's not a vegetarian option
six meals here and not even one of them
are vegetables we all accept you can
help you ma'am I new approach I've for
this time but all of the dish in here
can be substitute to which carrion
that's not a problem at all you don't
need to worry about it
knocks professionalism has carved a
potential mutiny
meanwhile the fish and meat eaters are
loving the starters beautiful flavors
complement each other amazing I would
definitely recommend but there's a
serious problem with one diners chicken
satay the chicken cooked it seems quite
fleshy inside and quite pink
it's absolutely yes give me that's pink
lemon don't most liking up factors
that'd be great thank you I will take
another 5 10 minutes all right sure you
don't expect from the top restaurant to
ask my food to be sent back to the
kitchen you order one chicken satay well
done Roy you leave them both the chicken
satay starter and the baby chicken main
course a half cooked pre-service and
finished up to order by kamyshev Nielsen
on this occasion he's got it badly wrong
if he part cooks the chicken you weren't
expected to go out thanks no he's very
annoying when we're dealing with the
people that we are dealing with tonight
there's no excuse for it
Mart's been quick to send up a
replacement dish but I want to see how
well this lift system works
in my restaurants I can bark orders at
my waiters over the pass but here every
dish that leaves the kitchen must travel
up two flights of stairs by dumbwaiter
to Mikey it's his job to send the food
to the right table
sous-sous they sending what day was that
I don't got an idea all the day what is
it but I should tell you what table is
before they send the [ __ ] thing man
yeah I actually don't know never what is
coming in the life I can only guess
seeing the food and carry it to the
ticket okay no he's selling food but no
one's told him what table in terms of
younger ticket ticket for this one yeah
so it's just sat there dying to see this
please Jesus come on so it's like this
yeah there's always like this yeah [ __ ]
me that's for 30 give a Z was like we've
got 300